pomiar kwantowej superpozycji jest tak samo losowy jak rzut monetą, ale jak daleko możemy posunąć tę
analogię, zanim się posypie? Dowiemy się tego dzisiaj w Qiskit w
klasie. Witaj w Qiskit w klasie – serii filmów, gdzie rozkładamy na czynniki pierwsze podstawowe koncepcje, które
możesz napotkać na kursie związanym z obliczeniami kwantowymi. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł podlinkowany w
opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Dzisiaj rozmawiamy o jednej z fundamentalnych zasad leżących u podstaw
teorii kwantowej – superpozycji. W naszym codziennym doświadczeniu obiekty zawsze mają określone cechy: ich położenie, rozmiar,
kształt, kolor – wszystko jest wyznaczone i pewne, nawet jeśli my jako obserwatorzy jeszcze tego nie zmierzyliśmy. W
świecie kwantowym niekoniecznie tak jest. Obiekt kwantowy może znajdować się w czymś zwanym superpozycją
wielu klasycznie dozwolonych stanów, które podczas pomiaru losowo zawalą się do jednego z tych
stanów. Mierzenie stanu superpozycji jest jak rzut monetą – nie ma sposobu, żeby z góry wiedzieć, jak wyląduje.
Ten fundamentalny indeterminizm jest niekomfortowym aspektem mechaniki kwantowej, z którym miał problem nawet Einstein.
Słynnie powiedział o tej losowości, że Bóg nie gra w kości, ale jak zobaczymy, Bóg jednak gra w kości, a w
naszym przypadku rzuca monetami. Co więcej, te monety są załadowane. Mierzenie kwantowej superpozycji może być podobne do
rzutu monetą pod pewnymi względami, ale sama superpozycja jest o wiele bogatsza i bardziej złożona niż klasyczny
stan probabilistyczny. Żeby to zobaczyć, zastanowimy się, jak działa klasyczna moneta i skontrastujemy to z naszą
kwantową monetą, którą zbadamy używając Qiskit na komputerze kwantowym IBM. Najpierw klasyczna moneta – to
całkiem proste: rzucasz monetę i ląduje albo orłem, albo reszką z 50% szansą na każde. W zasadzie moglibyśmy
obliczyć, na którą stronę moneta wyląduje, gdybyśmy znali dokładne warunki początkowe monety i dokładnie
ile siły i momentu obrotowego zostało przyłożone podczas rzutu. Ale w praktyce nie ma sposobu, żeby z góry wiedzieć, na którą stronę
moneta wyląduje. Dlatego używamy rzutu monetą jako kanonicznego przykładu klasycznego stanu probabilistycznego, gdzie
wynik jest zasadniczo losowy. Gdybym rzucił tą monetą tysiąc razy i zapisał liczbę wyników orła
i reszki, dostałbym histogram wyglądający mniej więcej tak. Mamy więc zliczenia na osi Y,
może to być orzeł lub reszka, i
histogram pokazywałby, że jest około 500 zliczeń każdego, z pewnym
odchyleniem statystycznym. Możemy stworzyć podobny stan używając qubitu na naszym komputerze kwantowym. Podobnie jak przy rzucie monetą,
qubit może być też zmierzony w dwóch możliwych stanach: zero i jeden. Jeśli zastosujemy coś zwanego bramką Hadamard do
qubitu, wprowadzi go w równą superpozycję zera i jedynki. Oto
wizualizacja tego circuit, który nazwaliśmy diagramem circuit. Tutaj górny drut to
qubit, a operacje zastosowane do qubitu pojawiają się jako pudełka na drutach. Bramka Hadamard jest pokazana jako pudełko
oznaczone H, a pomiar jest pokazany jako szare pudełko oznaczone małym symbolem pomiaru. Wysyła ten
pomiar do klasycznego bitu – tego drutu z dwiema liniami. Ponieważ qubit jest w równej superpozycji 0 i 1, gdy
go zmierzymy, będzie 50% szans na zmierzenie zera i 50% na zmierzenie
jedynki. Wyrażamy ten kwantowy stan superpozycji jako s = 1/√2 |0⟩
+ 1/√2 |1⟩, gdzie kwadraty każdego z tych
współczynników, zwanych też amplitudami, są prawdopodobieństwami zmierzenia każdego stanu. Więc w efekcie zastosowanie bramki Hadamard
jest analogiczne do rzutu monetą. I tak jak rzucaliśmy monetą tysiąc razy, żeby spojrzeć na
statystyki lądowania orłem lub reszką, możemy zrobić coś podobnego w Qiskit z naszą kwantową monetą.
Użyjemy prymitywu Qiskit zwanego sampler, który będzie wielokrotnie powtarzał circuit, żeby próbkować statystyki
wynikowego stanu. Przy tysiącu próbkach z powyższego circuit mamy coś wyglądającego zasadniczo identycznie
jak klasyczny histogram z monetą, z pewnym odchyleniem statystycznym. Czy to już wszystko? Kwantowe
superpozycje są zasadniczo tym samym co klasyczny stan probabilistyczny, podobny do rzutu monetą? Nie do końca. Ten film byłby
dość krótki, gdyby tak było. Żeby zobaczyć naszą pierwszą kluczową różnicę, spróbuję czegoś nieco innego z moją klasyczną monetą. Zamiast
po prostu pozwolić jej spaść na stół lądując orłem lub reszką, rzucę monetą i złapię ją
w powietrzu między dłońmi. Teraz moneta nie jest ani orłem, ani reszką, lecz jest albo orłem w lewo,
albo w prawo. Logika mówi nam, że i to powinno mieć prawdopodobieństwo 50/50, że jest
albo orłem w lewo, albo w prawo. Żeby zmierzyć orła w lewo lub w prawo na naszej kwantowej monecie, możemy zrobić to, co zrobiliśmy z klasyczną
monetą – mierzyć wzdłuż innej osi. Nasze standardowe pomiary na komputerze kwantowym są wzdłuż osi pionowej,
tak jak zwykły pomiar orła lub reszki na klasycznej monecie, ale możemy też zapytać naszą kwantową monetę, czy jest
orłem w lewo czy w prawo. Nazwiemy te dwa stany wzdłuż osi X plus lub minus.
Do tego użyjemy prymitywu Qiskit zwanego estimator. Żeby nieco skomplikować sprawę, zamiast zwracać histogram jak
sampler, estimator poda nam tzw. wartość oczekiwaną dowolnej obserwowalnej qubitu. Żeby
zrozumieć tę wartość oczekiwaną, powiedzmy, że dostajesz dolara za każdym razem, gdy moneta ląduje orłem, i tracisz dolara, gdy
ląduje reszką. Wartość oczekiwana to ile pieniędzy możesz oczekiwać zarobić średnio przy każdym rzucie. Ponieważ
jednakowo możesz zyskać lub stracić dolara, wartość oczekiwana wynosi zero. To samo rozumowanie można zastosować
do qubitu. Gdy szukamy wartości oczekiwanej x: gdy zastosujemy x do stanu plus, dostajemy wartość +1, a do stanu minus dostajemy minus 1. Więc gdybyśmy mieli
rozkład 50/50, dostalibyśmy wartość oczekiwaną zero. Ale tak nie jest – dostajemy wartość oczekiwaną plus jeden,
co oznacza, że moneta zawsze jest mierzona jako plus wzdłuż osi x. To byłoby jak rzucenie monetą,
złapanie jej klaśnięciem i zagwarantowanie, że głowa zawsze będzie zwrócona w prawo. Dzieje się tak, ponieważ
superpozycja to nie tylko rozkład prawdopodobieństwa. Pamiętaj, jak wyrażamy kwantowy
stan s równa się c0 razy stan 0 plus c1
razy stan 1, gdzie każdy z tych współczynników jest zespolony, co oznacza, że
WEBVTT
mają zarówno część rzeczywistą, jak i urojoną. Więc informują nas o prawdopodobieństwach, ale kryją też inną wielkość zwaną
fazą. Pewien współczynnik c można zapisać w taki sposób,
gdzie c równa się magnitudzie razy tej fazie, gdzie to fi jest
fazą. Jest to trochę jak faza fali, czyli położenie grzbietów i dolin fali. Jeśli dwie fale są w fazie
ze sobą, tzn. ich grzbiety i doliny się pokrywają, to połączą się, tworząc falę dwukrotnie
wyższą. Nazywamy to interferencją konstruktywną. Jeśli są w przeciwfazie,
wtedy interferują destruktywnie, całkowicie się znosząc. Żeby zobaczyć, jak faza może powodować
interferencję w naszej kwantowej monecie, spróbujmy zastosować Hadamard dwa razy zamiast tylko raz. Klasycznie
nie miałoby to sensu – jeśli zastosowanie Hadamarda jest równoważne rzuceniu monetą, to nie możesz rzucić monetą, która już się obraca. Ale zobaczmy, co
dzieje się kwantowo mechanicznie. Więc stosujemy Hadamard dwa razy i próbkujemy wynikowy stan.
Niesamowite – nie mamy już prawdopodobieństwa 50/50. Wynikowy histogram pokazuje, że w każdym przypadku mierzymy
qubit jako będący w stanie zero. Więc drugi Hadamard przywrócił qubit do stanu zero, od którego zaczęliśmy. To
nieco trudno zobaczyć na pierwszy rzut oka, ale to dzięki interferencji stanu kwantowego. Ale zamiast
interferować w przestrzeni rzeczywistej jak prawdziwa fala, interferencja zachodzi w abstrakcyjnej przestrzeni informacyjnej qubitu.
Drugi Hadamard spowodował, że część zero superpozycji interferowała konstruktywnie, podczas gdy część jeden superpozycji
interferowała destruktywnie i znikła. Zbadajmy dalej. Możemy zmienić fazę używając
czegoś zwanego bramką fazową. Więc teraz zastosujmy Hadamard, żeby stworzyć superpozycję, zastosujmy przesunięcie fazowe o
pi radianów, a następnie zastosujmy drugi Hadamard. Teraz wydaje się, że nasza kwantowa moneta zawsze wychodzi w stanie jeden.
Przesunięcie fazowe o pi zamieniło części stanu superpozycji, które były w fazie i w przeciwfazie.
Więc końcowy stan to jeden zamiast zero. To byłoby jak rzucenie monetą i w trakcie lotu bycie w stanie
zastosować operację, która gwarantowałaby, że zawsze ląduje orłem lub zawsze reszką, zależnie od operacji.
Niemożliwe w przypadku klasycznym, ale nie w kwantowym. Czego nauczyliśmy się z tych eksperymentów?
Ta nowa zdolność kwantowej monety wynika z jej fazy – właściwości, którą ma kwantowa superpozycja, ale której nie ma klasyczny
rozkład prawdopodobieństwa. Więc zwykły rzut monetą wcale nie jest świetną analogią do
superpozycji, bo nic nie mówi o tej fazie. Myślę, że możemy zrobić lepiej. Zrobię kolejny
eksperyment z naszą monetą. Mam monetę leżącą na stole orłem do góry. Żeby obrócić ją reszką, mogę po prostu ją przewrócić. To
obliczeniowy odpowiednik bramki NOT. Powiedzmy, że chcemy skonstruować operację, która zastosowana dwukrotnie byłaby
równoważna tej bramce NOT. Nazwiemy tę operację pierwiastkiem kwadratowym z NOT. Pomyślmy więc, co fizycznie robimy,
gdy stosujemy bramkę NOT: obracamy monetę o 180° wokół, na przykład, osi x. Więc gdybyśmy obrócili monetę
tylko o 90° wokół osi x, dałoby to nam pierwiastek kwadratowy z NOT. Więc zastosowaliśmy
nasz pierwiastek kwadratowy z NOT i moneta stoi teraz na krawędzi. Teraz możemy zapytać: czy to orzeł czy reszka? Cóż,
oczywiście żadne z nich. Ale moglibyśmy dodać krok do procesu pomiaru, żeby wymusić, że będzie to orzeł lub reszka. Teraz
moneta upadnie na stronę orła lub reszki z równym prawdopodobieństwem. W zasadzie moglibyśmy przewidzieć,
w którą stronę upadnie, ale w praktyce jest to wystarczająco trudne do przewidzenia, żeby uczynić to zasadniczo losowym. Jeśli chcę
zmierzyć, czy to orzeł w lewo czy w prawo, mogę przycisnąć go w tym kierunku w podobny sposób i znów da nam to 50/50
prawdopodobieństwo w lewo lub w prawo. Ale w tym wymiarze – orzeł z przodu lub z tyłu –
głowa jest już skierowana do przodu, więc 100% czasu zmierzymy ją z przodu. Więc podczas gdy pomiary w x i z
dały losowe wyniki, pomiar w y zawsze daje ten sam wynik. Jeśli wrócimy do
eksperymentu z kwantową monetą z poprzedniej sekcji, to przypomina to zachowanie kwantowej monety po
zastosowaniu Hadamarda: qubit był mierzony jako zero lub 1 z prawdopodobieństwem 50/50 w kierunku Z, ale
zawsze jako stan plus i nigdy jako stan minus wzdłuż X. Sugeruje to, że może moneta stojąca nieruchomo na
krawędzi to lepszy sposób wizualizacji stanu superpozycji qubitu niż moneta dziko obracająca się w powietrzu.
Zastosujmy bramkę pierwiastka kwadratowego z NOT na naszej kwantowej monecie w Qiskit. Mamy ten prosty
circuit. Następnie użyjemy estimatora, żeby sprawdzić wartości oczekiwane trzech obserwowalnych X, Y i Z, które są trochę jak
ściskanie naszej monety wzdłuż każdego z trzech wymiarów, tak jak właśnie pokazałem. Wartości oczekiwane wynoszą 0,
minus jeden i 0 odpowiednio dla X, Y i Z. To jest ten sam wynik, który
dostaliśmy dla obrotu pierwiastkiem kwadratowym z NOT zastosowanego do klasycznej monety. W rzeczywistości istnieje precyzyjna analogia między
monetą a stanem qubitu. Teraz możemy wizualizować stan qubitu jako wektor wskazujący w kierunku głowy
na monecie, prostopadle do jej powierzchni. Więc orzeł, czyli stan zero
na kwantowej monecie, odpowiada wektorowi wskazującemu pionowo w górę; reszka, czyli jeden, wskazuje pionowo w dół; i każda
równa superpozycja 0 i 1 wskazuje poziomo. Faza stanu kwantowego wyznacza dokładny poziomy
kierunek wskazywania, na przykład czy wskazuje wzdłuż osi x, wzdłuż osi y, czy gdzieś
pomiędzy. Ten wektor znany jest jako wektor Blocha i w pełni i jednoznacznie wyznacza kwantowy stan pojedynczego
qubitu. Możemy teraz na nowo wyobrazić sobie każdą bramkę, którą widzieliśmy w tym filmie, jako obrót lub serię obrotów na
monecie, czyli równoważnie na wektorze Blocha. Bramka NOT to obrót o
180° wokół osi x; zastosowana do naszego stanu zero, czyli orła, przewraca do
stanu w dół, czyli jeden. Pierwiastek kwadratowy z NOT to tylko 90° wokół tej samej osi x, startując
od stanu orła – obraca go do pozycji głową do przodu. Bramka fazowa to obrót o fi wokół osi Z; ponieważ
stan w górę jest wyrównany z osią Z, to nic nie robi monecie. Bramka Hadamard jest nieco trudniejsza –
początkowo porównaliśmy ją do rzucania monetą, wprawiając monetę w niekontrolowany obrót w powietrzu, ale Hadamard to w rzeczywistości
kontrolowany, deterministyczny obrót monety jak wszystkie inne bramki. Hadamard jest wykonywany przez obrót o 90°
WEBVTT
wokół osi Y, a następnie 180° wokół osi X. Więc zastosowany do stanu orła,
kończy się w pozycji głową w prawo. Więc nie ma niczego losowego w kwantowym stanie superpozycji ani w żadnej ze
standardowych operacji, które wykonujemy na qubicie. Każda operacja jest deterministyczna i odwracalna. Jedyny moment,
w którym losowość wchodzi do gry, to gdy decydujemy się zmierzyć stan kwantowy. To, czy kwantowy stan jest w superpozycji,
jest naprawdę tylko kwestią perspektywy. Jak prawdopodobnie się zetknąłeś, możemy swobodnie wybierać nasz
układ współrzędnych. X, Y i Z mogą wskazywać wzdłuż dowolnych trzech ortogonalnych kierunków. Więc
jeśli mamy superpozycję 0 i 1 w jednym układzie współrzędnych, możemy zdefiniować nowy układ współrzędnych, czyli nową tzw.
bazę, w której stan wskazuje czysto w kierunku plus Z i dlatego nie jest w stanie superpozycji.
Więc gdy mówimy, że qubit jest w superpozycji, musimy też zdefiniować nasz układ współrzędnych, czyli
bazę. Możesz wychodzić z tego modułu z wrażeniem, że właśnie usunęliśmy całą tajemniczość z mechaniki kwantowej.
W końcu jeden z rzekomo najdziwniejszych aspektów – stan superpozycji qubitu – jest naprawdę tak prosty jak
trójwymiarowy wektor. Pamiętaj jednak, że moneta to wciąż tylko analogia i nawet wektor Blocha to
tylko narzędzie wizualizacji do obliczania prawdopodobieństw wyników pomiarów. Nie możemy powiedzieć, co kwantowy
stan naprawdę robi przed pomiarem, bo sprawdzenie tego wymaga pomiaru. Omówimy ten
dylemat: jaka jest prawdziwa natura stanu kwantowego i jak kwantowe zjawisko splątania może nam pomóc
to wyjaśnić, w innym odcinku Qiskit w klasie – wszystkim o nierówności Bella. W międzyczasie, jeśli
chcesz pobawić się kwantowymi monetami i dowiedzieć się na własną rękę o stanach superpozycji qubitu i jak je kontrolować,
zajrzyj do modułu kwantowych monet podlinkowanego w opisie. Dzięki za oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem.